[Music]
and welcome back to an episode of
chapelle's world
the reason why we're uh we're giggling
is because we were
listen my environment here
is the best environment i love the team
that i work with because guess what we
just
you know we make fun of each other we're
rude to each other
uh we cut each other off
we don't want to finish each other's
sentences
we we
yeah
and i and i can accept that i can accept
ugly you know that was christian off
mike saying yeah that's crazy
ugly christian off mike saying i was
ugly and that's fine okay
i'm not i'm not i don't get weird when
people call me ugly that doesn't offend
me
it's your perspective you can have that
but you're objectively handsome
thank you see and you hear it you hear
it another way yeah one man's trash is
another man's treasure ain't that what
they say something like that something
like that something like that anyways
welcome back to another episode of
chappelle's world
uh with chappelle lacy himself
third third person lacy is what they
call me man
um
great things happening fun things
happening my band
mad peaceful
that is our name mad peaceful perfect
name yeah that's better than um the
first difference of opinion yeah way
better
way better although i still stand by
difference of a minion oh
but mad peaceful is it fits much better
listen only way i would do difference of
a minion is if we had like the minion
outfits like you have to do it you have
to do it that way and it would have to
be a hardcore band it can't be like
like google dolls or something like that
it has to be like
what's up guys we're difference of a bad
yard you know what i mean
and that's how it has to be and if it
ain't that way then what are we doing
maybe we start a band us three and
that's difference of a minion we could
definitely well there's only two
musically challenged people in this room
that's you and i
two musically challenged and one
mentally challenged oh so clever
meatball sit down i know sit down bro
with your dad's hair right gosh this is
yeah is that your boyfriend's is that
your boyfriend's shirt yeah
sit down
anyways yes so my band we have a name
now we're called uh mad peaceful and our
first show
is a uh is
this weekend saturday march 26th
at 7 p.m
i do have the flyer i should just send
it to casey and he could just put it up
it's the most listen punk rock flyers
you know like any shows are like
of bands just starting out the flyers
are always the funniest because i don't
get it but like maybe you guys might but
yes this is a funny flyer all punk rock
fliers are funny flyers because
look i think it's
i guess it's just because i've been in
comedy so long and i've seen comedy
flyers
and comedy flyers are
a lot better than that
matt peaceful we're playing with a la
soul slash thrash metal which i'm
excited to hear these guys hope fiend
and then major payne the leaders and
the leaders in damon wayne's influence
hardcore okay okay major payne
have you all seen that movie major
player yeah bruh
that movie his lines in that movie
were like some of the best and i hate
when people say they won't be able to
make this no more well okay cool it's
already been done and we're gonna leave
it we're gonna let major pain have it
that's where we're going to leave it at
stop saying we can't make this anymore
of course we can because guess what it
already happened yeah that's what drives
me crazy about that yeah
you can't it already happened we already
did it so why yeah yeah of course we're
not gonna make it anymore already
happened
you know you can't treat kids like that
yeah
yeah
in the 90s you could
in the 90s you could treat kids like
that you say whatever you want you man
if like if you told a kid like hey man
hey you better chill out before i pop
you in the mouth
hey that one you weren't gonna get
popped in the mouth
all right
maybe with my stepfather maybe
maybe but
i mean
listen a regular regular kid hitting
that hearing that you're fine oh you're
gonna get popped in the mouth
you see that video where that teacher
shoved or slapped that kid no recently
yeah dang it was somewhere indiana
not disney indiana but that's indiana
you know but yeah teacher straight up
slapped the kid
also what did that kid do
because i've done some bad things to
teachers all right i've done some bad
things what's the worst thing you ever
did to a teacher oh
there was one time i tried to drop kick
a teacher and i missed
okay so no harm no foul situation
dude i was
when i think about that bro i was in
i was in like the third grade
i was in the third grade and she said
something that made me mad and i and i
straight up went to drop kicker
and you just airballed yeah air
completely
bruh
power rangers was hot at that moment oh
yeah come on power rangers was popping
drop kicks
jackie chan movies were popping off
you
what else did you think i was gonna do
you think i was just gonna give her like
an easy kick like oh like that no no no
oh like a flying yeah yeah i flew at her
and
you know the best kick in my opinion is
like the band margera like flying double
kick
yes double kick where you're just like
you know you're also gonna that's that
liu kang bicycle kick if you know mortal
kombat
uh what else uh well i was in high
school
i tried to fight a bunch of teachers
because they tried to stop me from
fighting someone and i was sitting there
swinging at him
and and then my brother saw what was
going down
he threw a trash can at them
well not one trash can he threw two he
he threw two
trash cans
two trash cans yeah because the first
one missed
and so he was like maybe i can get him
again to get him away from my brother
and then but meanwhile you know what's
so funny about him throwing those trash
cans
i was right there
recipe's big bro but god damn
what the why would you
you mean you were right there like he
was going to hit he could have yeah was
he gonna hit me collateral damage and
it's so funny because that's it was back
in the day when uh my high school we had
the steel trash cans
yeah those sesame street the sesame
street oscar the grouch you know they
got rid of oscar the grouch why too
grouchy yup yep uh well because they
didn't want to promote that homeless guy
in a trash can they felt like it was
wrong couldn't do that now no you
couldn't do that now we already have it
just hey and uh going back to the we
can't do that now just go back and watch
major pain
and then you have what you wanted to
hear problem solved problem solved
anyways come see my band
saturday march 26 7 p.m mad peaceful
hope fiend and major pain we're playing
a skate shop called program skate shop
it's a skate shop slash record store and
this is in fullerton
uh
fullerton uh orange county area so i'm
actually pretty stoked man we've been
we've been practicing we had a three
hour practice last night
uh
we're we're really going for it
you know
we we have i think we're doing
six songs and two covers you know got to
get some coverage there because i'm you
know still writing you know like i said
i'm the i'm the daryl hall
of the group you know what i mean and uh
we're right we're still writing a bunch
of songs but it is but it is pretty
and it was crazy is like every guy in my
band
has has uh played
um has played in bands before so i'm the
only one that's like super super new
to this
uh i'm not scared of you i'm not scared
of you [ __ ]
okay i'm not terrified i know what i'm
doing
uh i've done some guest vocals before
okay i just haven't done a whole set
before i'm not scared of you guys
so if you try to mosh with me
when i'm
what a little scared
are you i'm a little scared
i'm a little scared
yeah toby keeps asking goes are you
nervous i go no first of all if i'm
nervous i'm not going to tell you i'm
not going to tell anybody that i'm
nervous
you'll never know but you'll admit it
i'll never tell
you know that's wrong anyways
but yeah i i don't know i'm excited
because
yeah i i've never done this in a way and
i i don't know
what my energy is going to be i know
what my energy is in practice you know
like how like performance wise but
when when it comes to people you know
it's i just don't know what it's going
to be like
you know because
i've only done parts of songs what can
you um have somebody shoot some video so
we could watch it here podcast yeah
kyle's gonna come perfect kyle's gonna
come and shoot some videos and stuff
like that and uh
and we'll you'll be able to see some
footage of how i get down
you know that's exciting and you may
think i'm crazy you're like dude this
guy's a psycho well it's been in my
brain forever
okay
dude i um
i discovered this drummer a while back
from this band
called crystal lake and i i don't think
i've ever seen
a metal drummer get down
as insane as this guy does i don't know
how to say his name
got kutara
got katara i think his name is he's the
drummer of this man called crystal late
starting from the top watch watch how he
gets down
my favorite part is when he screams
[Laughter]
listen someone showed me this a while
back and i've been obsessed watching
this dude
play and he doesn't even look like he
gets
tired this guy can play a whole set
like that
who can do that
this guy
got katara
gakutara
i think i'm saying that right
click on this page
casey
here's a scroll down a little bit
this one more a few more
and it's right
right that red red one
right there watch him do this fill
huh it'll start from the top again
because they just missed it
but watch but watch how freaking fast he
is
look at him
[Music]
and it's so effortless
i know you don't listen to me metal
casey but man
that
you gotta give that man appreciate it my
cousin uh
draw is a drummer um
double bass like he's a metal oh he's a
metal drummer yeah oh
well what's his name is he in a band is
he get down uh not anymore uh chris
denman is his name
chris dimon's your cousin
shut up you don't know i know yeah yeah
you had me for a half second did i get
you i i know i [ __ ] got you yeah no
dude i i've been obsessed watching these
guys anytime someone like tags me in
drum videos like that's the thing i love
watching the most oh yeah you're you're
cousin oh he
oh super metal he is oh he plays black
metal
there's a bunch of goats and [ __ ] and no
meatball that's not a racist term let's
see where your head's at
black metal is like norwegian black
metal like super intense [ __ ]
they paint their faces
uh bands like mayhem immortal
uh
wait is he
he doesn't play in a band anymore
no i'm trying to find a video looks like
he's opening up for pig destroyer
somewhere
are you trying to find a video wasn't
that a video
i don't think that was him though i
think it was attic
thing
and he's out in connecticut
uh yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
dude
shout out to your cousin and he says up
there i don't practice much anymore but
when i do i play
and he says he's slow and uncoordinated
no bruh he's he's still got it yeah he's
nice
yeah if my drummer ever you know just
sucks
what's up shout out to chris yeah is it
chris yeah is chris correctly yeah
correct
no shout out to that dude man yeah uh
i always appreciate like those that fast
drumming like that like where it sounds
like a like a machine gun
it's insane dude my favorite my favorite
drummer of all time uh uh one of my top
favorites
uh you know rest a piece was uh joey
jordison from slipknot i don't know you
didn't get it you didn't get into any of
that stuff huh it missed me it missed
you
you were you were in like ben howard
come on dude or ben harper is that what
his name is they're the same
right
that seems like that seems like a
connecticut thing ben harper ben howard
that hurts
all that weird guitar and i'm not i'm
not dissing that music i like it
i'm just saying
that missed me
if metal missed you then that missed me
well you actually don't even listen to
that music i don't know why i'm
attacking you whatever casey i get it
that's fine all right let's take a break
from this uh episode and talking about
the all the feels and let's talk about
the best kratom in the game right now
happy hippo uh i use kratom to fire up
my brain before any shows podcasts it's
like a limitless pill best focused
product i've ever used best part it's
all natural
visit
happyhippos.com and use promo code think
boy for for 20 off for life use that
code as many times as you want once
again that's happy hippo herbals.com
using promo code big boy for 20
off for life
i'm sorry i attacked your music someone
attacked me the other day
and a comment drop kick oh a comment
yeah they were like uh it was a nice
comment
kind of a backhanded you know one of
those backhanded
uh compliments or whatever they're like
you're actually kind of funny yeah yeah
[ __ ] you yeah exactly [ __ ] like that
this dude uh
i read i read i read a couple comments
you know
you see you know
sometimes you just take a look
you know
and i shouldn't have taken a look
and i'll never take a look again
but every once in a blue moon i'll take
a look
right
you know something you just gotta look
what was it what they say
they'll tell you you're slow rolling us
yeah i'm still rolling
it's because i'm just trying to not get
emotional
yeah just do it milk it take make make a
real meal out of it he
[Laughter]
this man
came to my page
and wrote no this dude goes man i
such a fan of
chappelle and what he does and i love
his podcast uh meaning chapelle's world
which is nice to hear
uh
and then he goes but i don't understand
his obsession with oasis they're such a
mediocre band
that cuts
deep first cut is the deepest
sheryl crow yeah
listen
i don't need you to understand
my obsession
it's my obsession
you know what i'm saying
like why why do you have to i don't get
i don't understand his uh
obsession i don't say that about
meatball i don't unders
with hockey
i don't get your obsession i get it as
his obsession he's from rhode island
that's what they do out there that's all
they have they hockey it up
and let them hockey it up ain't nothing
wrong with that yeah
but to sit there and go i don't they're
a mediocre band whenever people say
they're a mediocre band you haven't
heard enough oasis songs
i know for a fact
because here's the thing i i do this
if i don't like something i'll actually
like
before i give that judgment i'll listen
to all of it i will i'll give it a
thorough listen to make sure i'm not
crazy i'll give it a thorough thorough
thorough thorough listen
and then i'll say i don't like it
majority people don't do that how many
people you know actually do that when it
comes to music when it comes to a band
comes with artists and comes to album
and it comes to their songs how many
people you know do that
none you can do it with a movie it's
easy
because everyone's rolling a dice when
they go see a movie you know what i mean
exactly a trailer is what sells you
on going to see the movie
right
you know you can't really do that with
music
have you have you ever had a case where
you're like i don't like this i've never
been to court
and then
did a deep dive and then kind of came
around to it
or or have you had your first instinct
always been oh
that's a good question
shout out to casey kasem
um
i don't know if i i mean i would have to
really think about that one maybe we'll
save that for the next episode but i
would really have to think about like a
band that i did not like at first
and then
then when i heard something or took the
deep dive
man i don't know
that's a good that's a really good
question you know actually
actually
that's fair to say i'll say that with
with oasis because obviously everybody
knew
champagne supernova and wonder wall
right but it kind of was just like kind
of just existed
to me
right then i heard the song supersonic
and then i was like oh i need to take a
deep dive on this man and when i took
that deep dive
i was like oh this man is the world to
me
best brandon in the world to me
okay
people always talking about hey man why
why why the best band in the world
so needless to say i'm not going to read
any more comments because you guys are
mean no actually majority people are
actually really really nice
and he was still nice you know but he's
just
people just go i don't i don't get your
obsession well it's not for you to
understand
suffer you and i mean that in the nicest
way possible because i want to keep you
as a fan
[Laughter]
i was going to say are we going to have
to turn the set over here
and read hateful comments i'm a
sensitive guy
all right and i'm okay to admit that i'm
okay with admitting how sensitive i am
that's why i'm an oasis fan they have a
lot of sensitive songs songs that make
me
you know just gush
right
i'm not crazy
certainly not you know
you ever think you have you ever have
songs that just get you so emo they just
get put you in all your feels where you
just like
who was it john mayer is it a john mayer
song oh dude you think i'm like the
whitest connecticut guy of all time i
only said john may because he's from
connecticut oh yeah fairfield yeah
shout out to fairfax shout out to
fairfield shout out to jerry springer
uh fairfield he's he's from connecticut
oh okay right on
yeah what's the song that like gets you
olivia rodrigo
is it olivia bro you are on olivia
rodrigo and i haven't i haven't taken
the time to listen to her yet yeah kat
uh was talking about it that episode
yeah she taught yeah yeah i still got it
i still gotta
check her out if i really wanna feel sad
or like lean into feeling sad then you
go like elliot smith
elliot smith yeah
who's elliott smith he got big off of
being in good will hunting his song was
in good will hunting miss misery ellie
smith you don't know ellie smith no you
better show me a picture show me a
picture of elliot smith
he passed away
yeah
um you know um
on sunset
over by sun
that's him that's who that mural is yeah
yeah yeah yeah i was like who was on
that mural
that's who that is
because you know what's up
yeah i know the wall because i thought
it was eddie vetter
yeah oh that wall yeah never mind i was
thinking a different wall and so we're
like on yeah and silver like on sunset
never mind yeah thinking a different one
so that's i'll play the song for you
i'll we'll cut it out of the episode but
you'll you should know basically yeah
well this was in goodwill hunting which
uh kind of
made them bigger yeah oh that's totally
my style kind of reminds me a little bit
of sid barrett
nah a little bit uh steve barrett's
voice is a little dude i'm shocked you
don't know elliot smith no i know yeah
you should beat me up for that one
i know i always do that that's how it
used to be back in the day
if you had a song in a movie or anything
like that
boom it blew you up now it's tick-tock
now it's tick-tock dude some artists
been saying like
record labels are like um
like checking out people's like social
medias like like before they sign them
like you know what's your social media
engagement blah blah blah blah blah blah
before they sign them it's like man god
damn
they they make it tough what if some
people just don't like social media is
that fair
is it fair to like say no no all right
whatever we're on youtube right now yeah
i know yeah you're right nevermind i
love social media
wow
what it has done for me
this guy
[Laughter]
just
i mean
what there you go now we're back at that
now we're back now i'm back thank you
youtube for everything that you do
shout out to my sponsors youtube
no uh
you know i'm trying to think of
something like uh
it's not
i don't listen to like because i don't
listen to music when i'm sad but i love
a good song that'll put me in my feels
and the only reason why i said john
mayer because it wanted a john mayer
it's a john mayer song
slow dancing in a burning room you know
that one everybody knows that one bro
you hear that song it's just like oh
you just want to melt
you know what i mean that makes me
do all that put me in all the fields
it's it's an emo song but see all songs
are emo now and then they have pop punk
emo
pop punk is yeah
yeah
and it's making a comeback
but did it really ever leave
i felt like it was just always existed
because i feel like well i guess
back in the mainstream because i feel
like those pop punk bands are like we're
still all touring
can you hit me with some examples i'm
trying to think of like what qualifies
as a pop punk you don't listen to pop
punk
wha what kind of bands are pop punk
he said pop punk hmm
could you
use it in a sentence
i'll give you the original
[Laughter]
was walking down the street uh pop
punk's like
newfound glory
oh okay okay so like newfound glory fall
out boy green day blink one eight two
okay that makes it like of that genre
yeah but i feel like yeah i feel like
all those bands were like
still touring and like all doing really
well like with their success but it was
kind of like they were the staples so
they kind of like were able to hold
their ground now these newer
bands are starting to like you know
really
uh push it to like another level
right
yeah like that this guy kenny hoopla
you know he's got a dope song called
hollywood sucks i've heard of that guy
you got willow i was in this magazine by
the way
they did uh they did uh what do you call
it
feature a feature or yeah whatever they
did one of those things on me a shout
out to alternative press magazine which
is a magazine i've been
i mean who doesn't know alternative
press look at you were able to search it
yeah dude i how did you do that i just
typed in your name dude i love social
media
look at that pick dude yeah that's a
solid pig that's behind a bush or in
front of a bush
yeah handsome is all get out see yeah i
don't know what meatballs yeah i don't
know what you're talking about straight
hand of the mcdonald's diet i don't know
what the hell that means chappelle lacy
perfectly weaves the diy attitude into
his comedy work yeah
that's neat this is dope
yeah it was really yeah it was it was it
was super sweet of them
they're sweethearts
look at me just thinking in front of a
book look at me just [ __ ]
and camo you can't even see my see me
because i tried to do a camouflage joke
and it
tanked that tanked dude you want to take
it again yeah take it from the top uh
yeah man look at me in the camouflage
you can't see me
[Laughter]
nailed it dude i nailed it right there
thanks for giving me that uh that retry
casey shout out to casey for giving me
retries but uh
no so anyways yeah i feel like this pop
punk scene
is like really
you know
it a solid comeback and i
you you never you never got into that
either casey
not really
that's
what did you listen to
well i was influenced by like uh my
older brother he was huge into like bob
dylan
i listen to a lot of dylan they'll make
me fall asleep
bob dylan make you fall asleep yeah
you know how that hurtful comments
that's what just happened
he
[Laughter]
that's my favorite
that's how dudes cry
when they don't want to cry
just blow out blow it
dude when i was younger i remember
whenever i was getting fights bro
certain fights i cried after even though
i won like the fights because i'm
undefeated uh
i would still like [ __ ] be like
just crying
because i put all my emotion into the
fight
what a loser except that you did lose
that one fight with the teacher where
you airballed the dropkick i mean i took
a fat l on that one i took a fat l
how you miss how you miss a dropkick
straight up anyways but yeah i've been
listen i've been listening a lot of like
some of these newer bands uh some some
bands have been around for for a minute
but there's this there's this band i've
been obsessed with
called um stories the story so far
search these guys i think they're out of
northern california
you hear the way i said northern
california why did i say like that
i think they're out of northern
california i think yeah they're like i
don't know out of nowhere like they're
like norcal so they're like amazing but
yes this band right here
is amazing and guess what
you want to i found this out by doing my
deep dives on this band
that singer
see the guy in the parka
seeing the guy in the parka why do you
think he's wearing a parka
i'm guessing he's chilly
no
why do you think he's wearing a parka
who wears parkas all the time
fishermen
liam gallagher oh
he's an oasis fan
all right you guys just gonna get quiet
on me whatever
i thought you guys were gonna give me a
big round of applause just i thought
there was about to be fireworks and all
this [ __ ] that pop out we'll put it in
post
yeah you better you better put some type
of horns for that one
something that was
that was your reaction guys all right
whatever anyways this guy's an oasis fan
you know and but they're really really
good pop punk band and the guy uh the
lead singer has another band
that's kind of like this
you know what do you call it
when you blend yeah kind of
blend of uh hardcore
and like kind of pop punk vibe or
whatever dude's dope
i think his name is parker
cannon or something like that cannon
something like that but anyways dude
this this band
is really dope i've been i've been
yeah yeah parker cannon i think i posted
about i actually posted about
them on uh
my instagram no the chapel's world
yet because i talked about uh oh yeah
yeah so i'm gonna start doing this thing
on chappelle's world like these posts
where
uh uh go up uh casey
where the cherry is
right there so
um i
like i'll go through albums and i'll
listen to like the same like
it'll be like three or four albums where
i listen to them like consistently every
day
for like a month
and uh
and i was like why don't i share this
with people because i'm always finding
something that's dope and you know i i
think uh i don't know i just think it's
fun and i think it's something people
would have fun with since this is
chappelle's world and just letting
people more people into
the world of what i've been bumping but
uh but yeah that first one is this band
trapped under ice
uh which they're no longer a band
the i've i spoke about them before the
drama of
turn sorry the singer of turn style used
to drum for this man and then the lead
singer of this band has another band
called angel dust which is a really
really good band and then if you skip to
the next one
ice cube death certificate i talked a
little bit about it last time that album
top to bottom
you know you know what i love about him
like
what a storyteller
like it's literally like if you listen
to this album like he's just
telling stories
you know and it's like
it's not really like promoting i know
people went hard on them back in the day
you know especially like when when nwa
first came out and they were like you
know you're promoting kids to do this
this and this and this but
uh that's not what i took from this
album this is an album that i revisited
because i you know heard it as a kid
but like didn't really give it
you know all that i should have and i
think more so recently i just started re
revisiting
the this album and started taking you
know my deep dives into it and really
appreciating it and it's like yeah the
dude's just a
just a storyteller and tells it through
music he found his way of how to write
you know his songs and i think that's
[ __ ] dope and the next one is this
this uh story so far album
this is the album that someone had
introduced to me shout out to my homie
chase for introducing me to this
this album can't stop
can't stop so anyways
i'm gonna continue to post things like
that
um like every month i'll just post hey
these are the albums i've been ripping
through
um
this month and those are those are the
[ __ ] ones right now man so go check
out that trapped under ice heat wave
album death certificate in that story so
far
proper dose
album man it gets it it gets it gets no
better than that casey and casey you
better listen to him i will you actually
will yeah of course
really yeah
you do that for me yeah man yeah see
that's why i said i love the environment
here at chapel's world because we we
create a
very well
um
very well environment
well good said that's how you know i'm
lying that is not yeah it doesn't make
sense
yeah it's a very well
environment where
you know i just have people you know and
that's
that's how we do it we may call each
other ugly yeah all the time listen but
we support each other at the end of the
day we do support each other but you
gotta you gotta give metal a chance
all right
yeah yeah
what's a good like entry-level medal
entry-level metal
that's a good it's a good question
funny question that's a good question
entry-level
metal
damn
um
gosh because it's like weird cuz i don't
know if i take you like
to like the origins or
just
give you a solid idea like
damn
i'd say pantera
yeah go with vulgar display of power go
go with that one start off with that one
that's a good
entry
entry level um
let's see another one
i think
slipknot's
iowa album
would be
a good entry there's something kind of
metally that i like let me look it up
i'll cut this metally i like metally you
mean it's kind of it's more it's more
psychedelic yeah that's what i'm saying
it sounds like old school psychedelic
kind of
yeah they look like uh
click on a picture of them a lot of long
hairs and a lot of long hair mustaches
that is definitely the music they play
for sure
oh yeah they do have like a psychedelic
vibe yeah yeah
yeah that's like that that's like the og
you know like yeah we dig it like
sabbath they look like they they look
like they're all in black sabbath yeah i
could get down with psychedelic rock
yeah yeah i think yeah and it's i think
that's like origins of like you know
which eventually like kind of like
molds it into you know maybe it just
started to get i think when it just
started to get heavier yeah
you know there's so many
um
different types
you know there's a there's a lot of it
bro i'm uh i'm mad at uh
uh brendan and brian
cause they made fun of my um what'd they
do this time they made fun of my guitar
collection
what'd they say
because uh we were talking about
collectors like people people that get a
lot of money and then some people with a
lot of money
eventually just become people that
collect things you know like
like
there i think there was a guy on there
that collected trains
like he had a whole like like room where
it was just like full of trains like
train sets like moderate train sets yeah
yeah yep
and then obviously like the guy's gonna
collect actual trains that was a dumb
question
you know what's so funny when they were
first saying it i was like this movie
would just collect trains
[ __ ] weirdo what are you going to do
with that huh you can't even get space
for it yeah yeah
metro north yeah yeah exactly i was like
what [ __ ] want a metro link
[Laughter]
so sorry they were making not to derail
us that's not a train joke oh
but um they were making funnier guitars
side note did you ever whenever you were
a kid did they ever say like yo if you
put a penny on the track of the dorella
train yeah
i never tried it though it it doesn't it
doesn't huh no the train smashes it a
penny
a penny is going to derail a train yeah
12-year-old chappelle lacy who are you
uh but they were making fun of my uh
so they're like we could see you doing
that like when when you get like a lot
of money like being a collector thing
and i said oh the thing i would collect
would be guitars right yeah and like
some guitar they'll like appreciate and
value like exactly is worth more now
exactly and then they were like uh
then i don't know if they asked me or i
just said i was like oh yeah my my
guitar collection is you know roughly
you know around you know collectively
four grand
are you feeling what they're feeling
casey
are you hating on my
what what
nah dude um
no that's good
that's good hey listen
they made us as you eat a dick they made
it
no i'm just kidding how many guitars do
you have
f4
f4 but yeah collectively four grand
that
is that not a lot it's like a used
geoprism
it's like a 98 geo
it's not bad
it's not nothing you know the part that
made me mad about it the most is because
they started laughing and they were
trying they were doing the try not to
laugh so they were trying to like ask me
more questions yeah just laugh
don't hold it in
but like
4 000 that's a lot
i don't know why first of all listen
this is my starter
set yeah
good you got to start somewhere
somewhere
and what and what better way to start
off with a four thousand dollar guitar
collection
a five thousand dollar a five
no you'll get there i'm just i'm just
yanking your leg you'll get there
i will get there and i can't wait till i
get i collect the dopest guitars you
guys were like damn how much your
collection were i'm like 15 million wow
what's uh what's your like dream guitar
the
the one that noel gallagher plays is the
gibson es 355
go to the left i i want the red one it's
a red one that he plays
should i just say oh wait wait uh they
have a right uh do you see yep
right there
so the one yeah
i think she a beaut
isn't that a daisy
he's got a yeah this is the 355. he's
got a big head no
nose i got a big head leave him alone
it's the hair man the hair makes his
head look big
you grow your hair like that but yeah
that's what yeah yeah that's what he
plays the es355
yeah but that's like the what's that's
like the dream that runs i think that's
like six grand
so you'd have to trade in your whole
collection but i won
it's this one specifically
this one
yes
but yeah that's that's the dre that's
the dream guitar right there
you know
but yeah click on his
or zoom in on a little bit more because
he has this decked out
differently yeah
but yeah that's the
that's the one right there one day
one day act like i won't
act like i won't get it i believe in you
oh there's a solid picture of it the
below
this one uh to the right or yeah yeah oh
yeah yeah
no no the one uh
the one you had yep
that's it right there
that's that one
that's what it is
that's what it is 1960s 1960s 355.
brennan said when he said when i film my
first special he'll buy that guitar for
me said betcha sweet actually yeah and
you laughed at my forklift
and we'll produce it here at thick boy
we'll produce that special
i was about to dump this water on myself
with excitement
i told i said i told him i said i'll
film that [ __ ] tomorrow
i'll give you a eight minute special
doctor look i got a solid six yeah it's
all in six minutes dog you ain't [ __ ]
you don't know what's up
you don't know what's up man
uh
oh it's about that time dude let's do
let's let's hit these [ __ ] with
a playlist
we talked about
some bands that uh some pop punk bands
emo bands let's let's do some that um
let's do um
let's do the early november
something that produces
results
i like what you said no like he said
he
i don't know if you people remember
early november
they were back they were you know back
in the day like early 2000s
they were dope but that that song is
fire
um so we do it early november
let's do
we put elliott smith miss misery on
there do it yeah let's put ellie
jump on in casey
come on just because this is double
dutch baby let's go
i tried that one that one didn't really
work i tried
that was i was sorry i was focused on
messing up the spelling yeah um let's do
um let's do my friend's band let's do
the main
let's do the main
no no no with the e
and let's do
the song love and drugs
okay
and then let's go
with bayside
it's together it's one word
yeah no i know
[Laughter]
just called masterpiece
uh
yeah let's let's make this emo and fun
there's uh let's do this band called
joyce mainer
you got joyce right
no
m a
now you got me [ __ ] it up
uh
m-a-n-o-r
manor
whatever
you gotta say it right yeah you're right
you're right you're right you're right
that hey
you can have that one uh the song is
called heart tattoo
but we get we get what's wrong we get
bad emo with this playlist
um let's do a band called a rocket to
the moon
og
of the pop punk uh the poppy world
and let's do a song called uh
if only they knew
then there was this other band
called brighton
let's do brighton
and this song is called better way
bro i'm hitting y'all
i'm hit y'all
um
what other bands of that that world
uh
let's do saves a day
cars and calories
that's me
cars and calories
more so calories than cars but you get
what i'm saying right
you get what i'm saying
oh
who else bruh
how many is that
eight let's do th let's do uh oh
remember that band they used
they're still out there too man
uh
still used
we get an email noise and kisses
and there are noises and kisses i think
whatever you know what i'm saying
uh let's do one more like mad emo
hey this is hey this hey
uh jose fellas uh uh my people i don't i
don't know what to call you guys yet
i was struggling
and i'm the white kid from connecticut
hey fellas
hey i want everybody listening to this
playlist get in your [ __ ] feels get
in go in the corner put your headphones
in your airpods or your sonys whatever
you got
sit in that corner and just
feel
feel
feel
that's all i want you to do um
we'll do vanessa carlton song
this song is called white
houses white houses that's mad emo that
like to top off like the feels of like
emo
like
this is all you this like
people
hey you know what let's do let's do the
little fan engagement
let me know what you felt
not you don't have to let me know what
you felt just let me know what you
thought let me know your thoughts
thoughts on this playlist and like how
like
much it got you because i know when i
listen to this wait list always going to
get me
it's going to get me man i'm just going
to feel
but i'm going to feel in a good way and
that's fine
i'm totally okay with that bro have you
heard white houses re by the way reads
one slightly mean comment and now you
have a whole album of sad songs
you are sensitive
about you that we're just talking about
you see what i did sensitivity
you see what i meant that's the universe
when you listen when you listen to this
waitlist this is how you're going to sit
you're going to be like
and you're just going to feel like you
but you're going to smile
you know like as soon as you get out of
it it's it's going to be like a massage
all the feels it's a cathartic playlist
let those feels out let those feels out
let those smiles in lentil smiles in let
those feels
let the smiles end
man i wish i had a voiceover
to where i could guide people
through this [ __ ] playlist
and now you're on elliot smith
made popular by the feature film
goodwill honey
all right tour dates i got some tour
dates coming up uh hey salt lake city
what's up man what y'all got going on
out there i know y'all got a lot of
stuff man i don't think it's just like
mormons and all that but shout out to
mormons i love mormons man we got a lot
in arizona uh april 8th and april 9th
i'll see you salt lake city at wise guys
comedy club and then uh
april oh sorry may 6th and 7th new
comedy club in san diego called mic drop
comedy club get those tickets uh start
getting those tickets now man show me
love let me know that you guys are
covering this
uh and then uh may 12th i'm doing a
one-nighter in phoenix at a stand-up
live in the hometown just one night my
my drummer who's also a comedian joel is
going to be uh featuring for me there so
it'll be a great time and then also i
haven't added the date yet i need to add
them uh but in june i'll be in rhode
island what's up
what's up everybody like
and meatball come hang out all the
meatballs come out
yeah yeah meatballs gonna be making
meatballs yeah rhode island come out i
think it's june
yeah i'll put the dates on
on there but thank you guys for tuning
in and then once again fullerton this
weekend oh yeah once again this weekend
fullerton program skate shop i'm a band
mad peaceful man you know what i'm
saying mad peaceful yo
all right
peace
[Laughter]